[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara
guten abend und willkommen norbert
lehmann es auch wieder dabei wieder mit
deutsche medaillen genauso von mir und
das sind die wichtigsten themen von
heute
auf eskalationskurs moskau fordert die
usa auf alle truppen aus ost und
mitteleuropa abzuziehen wo es präsident
biden geht von einer russischen invasion
in die ukraine in den nächsten tagen aus
sturmtief über deutschland vor allem im
norden gibt es behinderungen auf straßen
und bahnstrecken schon morgen wird das
nächste orkantief erwartet
und bronze im skicross erst musste
daniela maier zittern dann nach
videobeweis gewinnt sie eine medaille
bei olympia
der ton zwischen russland und dem westen
wird wieder schriller us präsident biden
sieht alle anzeichen dafür dass moskau
für einen einmarsch in die ukraine
bereit ist moskau was weist das zurück
und verlangt einen vollständigen abzug
der us-truppen aus mittel und osteuropa
in der ost ukraine wird wieder
geschossen und die sorge ist groß dass
diese scharmützel eskalieren könnten
florian neumann
wann wird aus gefechten ein echter krieg
die frontlinie in der ost ukraine wo
auch heute wieder beschuss gemeldet wird
unklar wer dahinter steckt klar ist nur
jeder zwischenfall kann folgen haben
wir sind besorgt dass russland einen
vorwand schaffen will für einen angriff
auf die ukraine ergänzt uk auch heute
wieder veröffentlicht das russische
verteidigungsministerium bilder die den
abzug von truppen und gerät zeigen
sollen während der westen gestern
zweifel anmeldete wieder spricht er
heute mit nachdruck die aussehen sie tun
das gegenteil dessen was sie sagen 48
stunden haben sie ihre truppen um bis zu
7000 soldaten verstärkt wir nehmen die
wand wird aber wir werden sie an ihren
taten messen
zur selben zeit ein vertraulicher
austausch der eu-spitzen darüber wie
europa auf einen russischen angriff auf
die ukraine reagieren würde hinterher
bleibt man gewohnt vage wenn es zu einem
militärischen aggressionen gegen die
ukraine kommt dann wird das konsequenzen
haben und wir sind vorbereitet auch dann
mit sanktionen zu reagieren
möglicherweise schon bald der
us-präsident zumindest arg wenig später
er fürchte einen angriff in den nächsten
tagen
alles deutet darauf hin dass russland
bereit dazu ist die ukraine anzugreifen
und die warnungen werden dramatisch vor
dem un-sicherheitsrat beschreibt der us
aussenminister wie russland einen
vorwand für krieg schaffen könnte es
könnte ein fingierter terroristischer
bombenanschlag in russland sein die
entdeckung eines erfundenen massengrabes
in der ukraine ist ein vorgetäuschter
drohnenangriff oder ein falscher oder
sogar echte angriff mit chemiewaffen
singhammer weapons was passiert in der
ukraine
die welt hält weiter den atem an
warten wir nach bei unseren
korrespondenten in washington und in
moskau zunächst zu immer tee wissen wie
begründen die usa ihre einschätzung
ja präsident biden war sehr sehr ernst
als ja vorhin am weißen haus davon
sprach er rechne mit einem russischen
angriff innerhalb der nächsten tage
gestützt dass vor allen dingen auf drei
punkte das eine ist dass russland eben
so sagt das weiße haus in den letzten
tagen tausende von soldaten
zusätzlich dazu addiert hat zu den
truppen rund um die ukraine zum zweiten
dass es hinweise konkrete hinweise auf
mögliche fords fleck attacken gebe also
inszenierte gewalt um einen vorwand zu
schaffen für einen einmarsch und das
dritte und wichtigste ist sicherlich
dass die russische antwort hier im
weissen haus angekommen ist auf die
vorschläge der nato und des weißen
hauses darin sagt russland sehr klar das
ganze sei ein gesamtpaket die
forderungen und die maximalforderungen
abzug der nato-truppen aus osteuropa und
eben auch nicht beitritt der ukraine zur
nato die bleiben erhalten sei nicht
verhandelbar der us-präsident geht
trotzdem davon aus dass noch platz für
diplomatie ist eine außenminister hat
konkrete angebote vorhin gemacht aber
insgesamt ist die stimmung hier im
weißen haus doch sehr pessimistisch
gehen wir direkt weiter nach moskau zu
christiansen wir haben es gehört
russland erhöht jetzt sogar noch seine
forderungen und brot mit einer reaktion
wenn die usa darauf nicht eingehen wie
ist das zu erklären
in moskau ist man sauer wegen des
antwortschreiben ist der amerikaner der
vorwurf lautet vor allem dass die usa
sich einzelne punkte rausgepickt hätten
die für sie von vorteil sein aber auf
den kern auf das kernthema auf die
kernforderungen russlands dass es keine
weitere nato osterweiterung geben darf
da sei nicht eingegangen worden drauf
und deswegen will man hier weiter den
druck erhöhen man erhöht jetzt sogar
auch die forderung sie haben es schon
erwähnt dass die usa ihre soldaten
abziehen sollen als aus mittel und
osteuropa
und das klang vor zwei tagen ja noch ein
bisschen anders als bundeskanzler stolz
hier war da haben wir beide den dialog
betont davon ist jetzt nichts mehr zu
spüren russland betont zwar weiterhin
auch und sagt es werde keine invasion
geben und man wirft dem westen vor
hysterisch zu sein dankeschön nach
moskau und washington christian siemund
mrt rissen
nach deutschland hier hat in der nacht
das wetter viele um den schlaf gebracht
und einiges chaos ausgelöst seit dem
frühen morgen ist das sturmtief elena
von westen über deutschland
hinweggezogen und hat vor allem in der
nordhälfte schwere unfälle verursacht
doch es ist wohl nur ein vorgeschmack
auf das was ab morgen nachmittag auf uns
zukommt christoph distel hat mehr
heute morgen auf einer elbfähre in
hamburg der sturm tobt die wellen
schlagen von vorne auf und dann durch
die sicherheitsscheibe
das wasser schießt in den innenraum ein
riesenschreck für alle regelrecht
zerbröselt sei die scheibe erklärt ein
sprecher später und doch wird nur ein
mann leicht verletzt
zwei andere haben im orkan keine chance
in bad bevensen südlich von hamburg
kraft am vormittag eine eiche quer über
die landstraße und direkt auf einen
wagen der fahrer stirbt noch bevor die
feuerwehr in bergen kann fast genau so
kommt auch ein mann im landkreis uelzen
ums leben auch den bahnverkehr bremst
der sturm aus wie hier am hauptbahnhof
hannover viele reisende blicken
ärgerlich auf die anzeigetafeln höheren
ratlos die durchsagen naja eigentlich
nur dass die züge immer weiter ausfallen
aufgrund des sturms
mehr informationen kriegen wir leider
nicht doch gerade zu den ausfällen im
fernverkehr steht die bahn hat aus
früheren unwetter gelernt die strategie
bei sturm gar nicht erst losfahren wir
wollen damit vermeiden dass züge bei
diesen wetterbedingungen auf freier
strecke stehen bleiben und dann wird es
schwierig sich um 300 400 oder 500
reisende gleichzeitig zu kümmern etwa so
geht es den passagieren der aida prima
gestern schon hätte das kreuzfahrtschiff
die elbe nach hamburg einfahren sollen
wartet jetzt vor helgoland bis sich der
sturm gelegt hat der erste sturm
wohlgemerkt der zweite kommt ja noch mit
mehr wucht
während das tiefe lenia das uns ja heute
beschäftigt hat sehr langsam gezogen ist
und viel wind über viele stunden
gebracht hat wird das team xenapp ein
schnellläufer tief sein das ganz rasch
durch deutschland bietet mit viel
höheren windgeschwindigkeiten
ab morgen nachmittag so ist also zu
befürchten werden manche der jetzt schon
so durchgeschüttelten bäume einem
zweiten orkan kaum noch etwas entgegen
setzen können
und jetzt nach mali in afrika kanada und
frankreich wollen ihren anti terror
einsatz dort beenden wegen spannungen
mit der malischen militärregierung auch
die bundeswehr ist in dem
westafrikanischen land stationiert 300
soldatinnen beteiligen sich an einer eu
ausbildungsmission weitere 1000 sind
teil einer friedenstruppe der vereinten
nationen ein gefährlicher einsatz ohne
die rückendeckung frankreichs wird im
mehr als fraglich ist ramms
französische soldaten im kampfeinsatz in
mali bald wohl ein bild der
vergangenheit sie werden abgezogen
präsident makro will die mission beenden
das verhältnis somalischen militär unter
zerrüttet
ist wir können nicht militärisch
engagiert seien an der seite von
machthabern der an strategien versteckte
ziele wir nicht gutheißen das ist aber
die situation mit der wir heute in mali
konfrontiert sind der kampf gegen den
terrorismus kann nicht alles
rechtfertigen
das land nicht befriedet terror gebiet
militäroffizier simi kräuter putschte
sich an die macht versprochene wahlen
verschiebt er um fünf jahre russische
söldner der gruppe wagner berüchtigt für
menschenrechtsverletzungen holte runter
ins land offen was nun aus den mandaten
wird an denen die bundeswehr beteiligt
ist im rahmen eines eu mandats bildet
somalische soldaten aus mit der
un-mission - war wenn sie das land
stabilisieren ohne französische
kampftruppen sind diese mandate nicht
mehr geschützt es ist bisher gelungen
über französische fähigkeiten und wenn
das jetzt fehlt dann werden wir dringend
eine lösung suchen müssen dass
deutschland die aufgabe der franzosen
übernimmt unwahrscheinlich dafür fehlt
der politische wille ein abzug
allerdings birgt risiken was hat das für
europa zur folge und zufolge könnte es
haben deutlich mehr terror der nach
europa überschwappt und millionen von
flüchtlingen die wenn irland de stabil
ist sich auf den weg nach europa machen
nach afghanistan wollte man mandate und
ihre ziele kritisch hinterfragen exit
strategien vorbereiten die zeit drängt
das nun in mali umzusetzen
wer sind diese russischen söldner die
längst nicht nur in mali auftreten
moskau sagt der russische staat habe
nichts mit ihnen zu tun doch daran gibt
es erhebliche zweifel
ein camp russischer söldner in mali
aufnahmen des französischen fernsehens
mehrere hundert mann soll in dem land
seien ausbilder und kämpfer bezahlt der
helfer der militär unter und eine art
stoßtrupp für russische interessen
moskau bestreitet jede verbindung
kremlnahe experten sprechen von einer
unpolitischen sicherheitsfirma ja das
tue ich denke dass molly die regierung
von mali die private militärfirmen
wagner angeheuert hat weil man ihr
vertraut und weil sich wagner and
gegensatz zu den französischen beratern
nicht in die innenpolitik marlies eilig
russische internetseiten feiern die
gruppe wagner ihr gründer liebt nazi
symbolik ex-offizier dimitri otc
inoffiziell gibt es seine söldner firma
gar nicht viele seiner leute kommen aus
dem russischen militär erster kampf
verdeckte operationen bei der russischen
addition der krim 2014 in syrien sind
sie seit 2005 dabei und helfen mit
staatschef assad adam zu halten libyen
unterstützen sie 2009 10 mit mehr als
1000 mann eine offensive gegen die
zentralregierung und jetzt mali
russische sollten am einsatz für immer
mehr machthungrige in afrika und für die
strategischen interessen moskaus
mali dürfte auch thema sein beim eu
afrika gipfel in brüssel dem ersten seit
fast fünf jahren ein streitpunkt die
bessere versorgung afrikas mit corona
impfstoffen auch umstritten ist der
ausbau erneuerbarer energien die
afrikanische union will weiter auf kohle
setzen ihr kontinenten zeigt kaum
industrialisiert und habe nicht zum
klimawandel beigetragen
fast zwei jahre war die amerikanische
botschaft in berlin unbesetzt jetzt
zieht eine frau als botschafterin ein
amy goodman
bundespräsident steinmeier empfehlen die
politikwissenschaftlerin heute im
schloss bellevue die 72 jährige war
bisher hochschulpräsidentin in den usa
für goodman ist es eine rückkehr zu
ihren familiären wurzeln ihr jüdischer
vater war 1934 aus nazi deutschland
geflogen
schauen wir auf die korona lage und die
angekündigten lockerungen am 20 märz
soll ja auch die pflicht zum home office
wegfallen dgb chef hoffmann fordert nun
langfristige regeln damit millionen
beschäftigte auch weiterhin zeitweise
von zu hause arbeiten können im
einzelhandel in nordrhein westfalen
fallen an diesem samstag sämtliche
zugangsbeschränkungen darunter die
zweijährige und niedersachsen will die
korona masken pflicht für schüler im
unterricht vom 21 märz an stufenweise
abschaffen die aktuellen zahlen dazu die
bundesweite sieben tage incidents ist
weiter gesunken auf gut 1300
85 die gesundheitsämter meldeten dem rk
ii dazu
626 neuinfektionen das sind 12 1236
weniger als am vergangenen donnerstag
400.000 neue wohnungen pro jahr
klimafreundlich und bezahlbar dass es
ein zentrales ziel der koalition dafür
wird sie viel geld aufbringen müssen
bauministerin klara geywitz hat heute
zusätzliche mittel für den bau von
sozialwohnungen versprochen und gleich
dazu gesagt dass das nicht reichen wird
es braucht aber nicht nur geld sondern
auch neue ideen und konzepte sylvia
bleßmann berichtet diese platte hat
potenzial noch einmal drei stockwerke
kommen aufs dach des ddr typen baus in
berlin-buch die hälfte der wohnungen
sozialbau also mit sechs euro 50 den
quadratmeter bezahlbar obwohl holz und
stahl aufbauten kostentreiber waren
rechnet sich die aufstockung der keiner
grundstückspreise anfielen ich bin im
moment noch insgesamt positiv denn wir
ertüchtigen ja auch die bestandsgebäude
unten drunter insofern ist es für mich
fast alternativlos wir werden sozialen
wohnungsbau auch auf den dächern in
unseres bestandes haben weiterentwickeln
und so könnten bald mehr menschen auf
dächern alter plattenbauten leben oder
in umgebauten büros in bis zu 4,3
millionen neuen wohnungen
geben deutlich mehr umbau setzt die
regierung auch auf mehr neubau ein
aktueller kosten check zeigt jedoch dass
der neubau am teuersten ist gefolgt von
modernisierung ausbau und aufstockung am
günstigsten ist der umbau von
bürogebäuden in diesem neuen
wohnquartieren bei den hellersdorf
konnten nur mit kaffee fördergeldern
bezahlbare wohnungen entstehen bei
explodierenden baustoff kosten und hohen
klimaschutzauflagen ist die regierung
und der handlungsdruck eben zufolge bin
ich dabei habe ich heute auch
angekündigt eine zweite milliarde für
den sozialen wohnungsbau auf den weg zu
bringen auch mit dem e h 55 standard
auch mit blick auf das klima der staat
wird tief in die tasche greifen müssen
um die ehrgeizigen wohnungsbau ziele zu
erreichen
nach brasilien dort ist die zahl der
toten nach der unwetterkatastrophe auf
mindestens 104 gestiegen in der
betroffenen bergregion von rio de
janeiro suchen helfer und angehörige im
schlamm nach weiteren überlebenden
dutzende menschen werden noch vermisst
am dienstag hatte es innerhalb kurzer
zeit so viel geregnet wie normalerweise
im gesamten februar die wassermassen
lösten mehrere erdrutsche aus
jetzt bist du deppert mit einer hart
erkämpften silber medaille für die
deutschen kombinierer ja es war vor
allen dingen ein drama um dreifach
olympiasieger eric frenzel nach gutem
sprung brach er im rennen ein erschöpft
und unterkühlt aber das deutsche team
das schaffte ein kleines wunder dank
schlussläufer vinzens geiger sie
springen und sprinten sich zu silber die
nordischen kombinierer manuell heißt
julian schmid und vinzenz geiger erik
frenzel fehlte bei der blumenzeremonie
war nach seinem lauf völlig ausgepowert
ich habs gerade eben erst erfahren dass
wir silber geholt haben von dem her ja
ich bin überglücklich
dass ich das die drei bis quasi
ausgemerzt haben sich jetzt hier soll es
in bagdad zum schluss eric frenzel mit
guter sprung leistung auf der strecke
allerdings kann er nicht ganz mithalten
für ihn der erste wettkampf nach beendet
der cola quarantäne in einem packenden
rennen sicherte schließlich der starke
schlussläufer vinzenz geiger platz zwei
hinter norwegen überraschend bronze an
japan
und bronze nach videobeweis daniela
meier wird im skicross finale der frauen
dritter und holte damit die erste
deutsche olympia medaille in dieser
disziplin nachdem die jury nach
wettkampfende minuten lang über einen
regelverstoß durch einen konkurrentin
beraten hatte
tränen nach der überraschung skicross
daniela mayr bekommt ihre medaille
zugesprochen die 25-jährige wurde
hochgestuft nach jury überprüfung dieser
behinderung verursacht von ihrer
schweizer konkurrenten fanny smith
ich habe meine ich jetzt gedacht dass
ich würde wohl aber also es ist
natürlich umso besser sie hat mir da
schon besser den speed genommen das
erste ski cross gold geht an die
schwedische weltcup dominatorin sandra
nissen und silber an die kanadierin
merial thompson für deutsche ski
freestyler ist es erst die zweite
olympische medaille überhaupt
der druck war groß auch wegen der
dopingvorwürfe vielleicht zu groß für
camila verleger war die russische gold
favoritin verpasste ihrer eiskunstlauf
kür und wurde nur vierte die große gold
favoritin den tränen nahe die positive
dopingprobe und der wirbel um ihr
startrecht bei diesen olympischen
spielen hatten der 15-jährigen camila
weil ihr war offenbar so stark zugesetzt
dass die sonst so sichere athletin
gleich mehrere sprünge verpatzte war
lieber weit entfernt von ihrer
bestleistung lief nur die fünftbeste
kühe und gewann am ende noch nicht
einmal eine medaille nur platz vier für
die russische wunder läuferin gold gegen
dennoch nach russland durch die 17
jährige anna scherbakowa
mit einer wirklich wunderbaren kür kann
man sich in voller länge bei uns auf
sportstudio daewoo das doch ein schöner
hin bei vielen dank nach dem sturm ist
vor dem sturm wie das konkret bei ihnen
morgen aussieht sagt gleich katja
horneffer marietta slomka begrüßt sie im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn wir
danken für ihr interesse und wünschen
ihnen noch einen schönen abend bis
machen sich nur auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten amt heute war es ja sehr windig
mit dem tiefen ligna und nach dem tiefen
ja dass in den vergangenen 24 stunden
hier über uns hinweggezogen ist kommt
gleich ein neues tiefen daher senat
heißt das und das bringt sehr milde luft
nicht es gab orkanböen selbst im
flachland zum beispiel in göttingen mit
119 kilometer pro stunde spiekeroog
meldete 125 kilometer pro stunde jetzt
in der nacht des höchstens noch an den
küsten etwas stärker sonst wird das eine
ruhige nacht mit etwas regen oder auch
mal etwas schneeregen bei
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 7 und 0 grad
am morgen wird es sehr mild im süden
baden württembergs und bayerns steigen
die werte auf 14 bis 18 grad sonst
bleibt es bei sieben bis 13 grad etwas
kühler
am vormittag können sie die sonne sehen
zwischen der ostseeküste und dem
erzgebirge und auch in süddeutschland
von westen kommt das nächste tief heran
es bringt viel regen mit und der
erreicht am nachmittag dann auch den
osten dann geht es kräftige schauer und
gewitter und auch wieder orkanböen der
höhepunkt des sturms wird wie in der
nacht zu samstag erreicht am samstag
verlässt uns das orkantief ostwärts
windig und wechselhaft geht es weiter
guten abend